hey folks if you'd like to support me or
this channel move university in creating
more video tutorials then please
consider making a financial contribution
at my website booth university calm
thanks and enjoy the video so in this
video I want to begin talking about
sphingolipids in more detail before we
talked about the general structure of a
sphingolipid but they were kind of weird
because they showed up under
phospholipids and under glycolipids so
here I've done a different general
structure of sphingo lipids still has a
sphingosine backbone it still has the 1
fatty acid attached but instead of
putting a phosphate and an alcohol or a
carbohydrate portion I know that that is
either way the polar head group so I've
just written it here as X writes XS and
I represent some polar head group so
let's actually see what this looks like
so here is the sphingosine portion in
purple there is the sphingosine portion
in purple and we can see here that if I
if I reveal the numbering of these
carbons this first one is carbon number
1 down here and there's 2 & 3 those
first 3 carbons of the sphingosine
backbone are analogous the situation
with glycerol so glycerol had only 3
carbons and those 3 carbons were the
backbone of the structures of the other
the other molecules we've talked about
thus far here the first 3 carbons are
pretty much playing the same role as
though the 3 carbons of glycerol now of
course the rest of these carbons at the
top here kind of extend extend out this
way at least just in this general
structure but that's kind of taking the
place of what where the the fatty acid
would normally be in the lipids with
glycerol backbone now at the carbon
number 2 carbon number 2 we have the
fatty acyl portion right and that
portion is usually coming from a
saturated fatty acid or a mono
unsaturated fatty acid with 16 18 22 or
24 carbons
when it comes to single lipids and this
acyl group is actually connected here at
carbon number
to to this nitrogen via an amide linkage
so this here is an amide bond so at
carbon number two we have an amide bond
now over here we have at the one carbon
we have this o and we have this polar
head group being attached so the nature
of this this polar head group basically
determines what past Fingal Lippman we
have so this bond here is pretty
important this bond is a phosphodiester
bond if X is a phosphate group or
contains a phosphate group now
that would mean that this Fingal lipid
would be a phospholipid right because it
would contain a phosphate group so we'd
have a sphingo phospholipid or a phospho
Stingo lipid I don't know which one if
either one is correct but both should
make the same same amount of sense to
you but this bond might not be a
phosphodiester bond
it could be a glycosidic bond and it
would be a glycosidic bond if X was a
sugar or a carbohydrate portion right if
that was the case we'd have a glycolipid
so or a glycosphingolipids Pingo glycol
lipid the point is that either way it
should make sense to you what's going on
there now what is the simplest
substituent that we could have for X
what if it's neither of these what if
it's not there's no phosphate there's no
sugar portion or if it's just an H well
then you have what's called the parent
compound of the single lipid and its
name is ceramide okay cool so now that
we've talked about that I hope you
understand so far the structure of us
being a little bit let's talk about the
subclasses three subclasses of
sphingolipids
they are categorized based on what's
attached as the polar head group so
we've got single nylons
glycosphingolipids and gangliosides so
if your X is is a phosphor coating or a
phosphoethanolamine you have a
sphingomyelin and tingle my lens are
present in the plasma membranes of
animal cells and there's lots of them in
myelin myelin you might know or you
might not know is is what helps insulate
axons of certain neurons and so because
my lens are single islands are
especially prevalent in there they're
actually given the name as Fingal nylons
because of that because of their
prevalence in the myelin sheath so
that's Fingal islands if you have
phosphocholine or phosphoethanolamine
right you
have these this would be sighs these
guys because they have the fossil
portion right these are phospholipids or
sphingo phospholipids so they are
phospholipids now glyco sphingolipids
basically is when the X is one or more
sugars okay so if you have one sugar or
more sugars you have a
glycosphingolipids
but now um now these glycol
sphingolipids are also called a neutral
called neutral like Oh lipids and we'll
get to why in just a second
in fact I'll even mention it now they're
called neutral Ifill lipids because when
you attach a sugar as the polar portion
these sugars don't have charges right so
there's no there's no nowhere else in
the finger seen or or the from the fatty
acid chain right there's no other place
where there's a charge so if the sugar
that you're adding doesn't have a charge
which sugars don't have don't carry a
charge then you have a neutral molecule
overall so these these
glycosphingolipids are going to be also
called neutral glycolipids sphingomyelin
as you might imagine because they have
the phospholipid they're not always
neutral okay so now this is one or more
sugars is is if the X right is equal to
that so it's further classified so Lycos
sphingolipids are made up of cerebral
sides and global sides so repro sides
basically when you have just one sugar
so let's kill that s there and global
side is when you have two or more sugars
so sorry bro sides if the one sugar is a
glucose the one sugar is a glucose you'd
expect that that that membrane lipid or
that cerebroside specifically to be
present in non neural plasma membranes
if that X is instead galactose if the
one sugar that's attached is galactose
you'd expect that to be present in
neural plasma membranes now
Lobo sides have two or more sugars
attached as that X polar head group so
that X can be a combo of glucose you
could have galactose you could have n
acetyl beta galactosidase attached as
the polar head group and these
glycosphingolipids are actually
important for blood typing so like a B
and O a B so these are important for
blood typing fun fact okay now on to the
the next class is gangliosides and these
are actually the the most complex of the
bunch now X is an oligosaccharide with
at least at leases in all caps they're
one n-acetyl neuro minute a sativa is an
EU v AC which is a sialic acid what does
that even mean an oligosaccharide
basically means you have multiple
multiple sugars attached right in a link
and there's at least one of these sialic
acids I'll actually show you a sort of
depiction of each of these in the next
video I just want this video to be too
long
so each of these these these sialic
acids carries a negative charge a
negative charge at a pH 7 so they're not
they're not like global sides or or
cerebral sides so um the first thing is
that the reason why I put only unlike
global sides here is because cerebral
sides only have one sugar low besides
have two or more sugar so globe asides
and ganglia sites are can be fairly
similar in their structures because
global sides will have may have you know
three sugars and the ganglia side might
have three sugars the difference between
them is simply that gangliosides will
carry this sialic acid and the sialic
acid will give it a negative charge so
it's not going to be neutral like a
globocide hence unlike
besides so gangly sighs you can kind of
imagine them as global sides with this
acidic portion and therefore will have a
negative charge
now ganglia sides can sometimes be
classified based on their series which
is the series is based on the number of
the sialic acids are attached to in that
polar head group portion so if there's
one sialic acid to be called part of the
G M series which will probably be
ganglia side mono if there's two to
sialic acids you have GD d diming two if
there's three of them G t-try four of
them GQ core or quad basically the
classified for the number of sialic
acids that are contained in that certain
polar head group so I hope that video is
helpful and in the next video we'll talk
about some examples of these structures
anyway I hope that is helpful thank you
for watching yo if you found that video
helpful don't forget to Like comment
subscribe for more content and if you
know anybody who might find the video is
helpful then please share with them
thanks happy studying